the other side the coin lost to that you
know over a millions and billions of
years the planet continues to get bigger
because as trees grow and they die and
you know the planet actually gets
actually larger it affects the way the
planet spins he got into great detail
about how does the pennant get larger
when you figure out it trees grow you
ever you ever go to a forest and see how
thick the underling is where all the
leaves are mass of the earth the master
literally gets bigger and it actually
what it does is there's also groups out
there that say that like as an example
remember the brontosaurus real long
lizard long neck yeah there are groups
that will tell you now because of the
environment here that animal could not
live its heart could not push enough
blood throughout his whole body cuz they
were so big if you look at the
pterodactyl maybe that remember the
pterodactyl bird that kind of flew it
was a sign like a lizard he said in
order for those to fly you had to have
the right environment because they
didn't have legs or they could run and
get up off the ground they had like
claws and the tips of their wings and
they had these real short legs like they
were hanging on to something and would
let go and either go into a right off
the bat go into a glide or and enough
where they could flap their wings one
time and get up high enough where they
could now fly in order to do that you
need low pressure so he believed that
the earth had low pressure around it he
also believed that dinosaurs lived at
the same time that that man was here and
that they kind of coexisted together and
that over time you know as the the
atmosphere changed those animals could
no longer adapt to it
and they ended up dying off which again
well the atmosphere definitely changed
when the comet hit the earth completely
definitely blacked out the sky and sure
stopped things from being able it was
that part of that I mean they say listen
when you when you go back and you start
looking at some of these people that
were in the Bible how old they were and
you figure out that Moses was what five
to seven hundred years old and so when
he brought that up I thought well that's
interesting yeah okay why do you think
that isn't goes well I don't think the
Sun was cooking everybody back then so
the radiation from the Sun now is really
what kind of at the end of the day does
us in and he said back then they didn't
have that so they live these crazy long
lives like that I mean he also believed
that all of the
the gods they talk about Zeus and all of
the others that follow under him were
real and that we we ourselves just like
the Bible says you know if your God made
us in his likeness okay well he said if
the administer his likeness and he was a
god we kind of we strive to be gods too
and I said I understand that would mean
by that he goes listen we want to fly we
would have control the weather we want
to you know swim underwater and be able
to breathe these are things that gods do
and we perfected those we now you know
we can make it as cold as you want the
house gonna get us hallelujah on the
high speed control all the elements hmm
so you know you start kind of taking
some of this into consideration like why
maybe I mean again it's all part of the
theory people have this ideology of
where we came from and what we're doing
here and where we're going and the
aliens is that all is it all together
it's all really about the earth keeping
it healthy at the end of the day and
these these beings like I say I've
always been here
project disclosure came out in 2012 they
had 44 members project disclosure
project disclosure came out I want to
say 2012 mmm-hmm
it was set up with 40 different members
who were all these were all real high
military personnel these were guys that
work within the federal government for
you know different agencies the NSA and
each one of these guys came out and told
a little story this guy calls himself
Steven Greer his name is Steven Greer he
calls himself a UF fall ufo-ologists you
have follow gist UF ologist you have
olive he's actually an emergency room
doctor is what he really is
oh really he's an emergency room doctor
which makes the story even more so
amazing because himself guy in here and
the great guy and listen hey Lazar lives
here to lose our lives in Coral Gables
Florida
does he really yes he does he lives
right here in Florida he's an
interesting dude oh yes no poor
interesting again look at element 115
and that's oh another weird thing I want
to talk I don't want to interrupt but
before we get off this topic the Bob
Lazar [ __ ] is so weird going back to
talking about the UFO that is hit in
Brazil how some of that stuff's
disappearing off Twitter disappearing on
reddit I was searched now Bob Lazar did
podcast with Joe Rogan which is one of
the Joe Rogan's biggest podcasts got I
mean he's got 11 million views it's
definitely top 10 percent of the podcast
as far as like popularity if I go on
YouTube and I search Joe Rogan Bob okay
it does pop up so this is you still
gotta look it's not shadow band maybe
that was just me for some reason they're
trying to ban me me I've been looking at
too much UFO [ __ ] there's like Danny you
cutting you off anyway stranger things
happen what are we talking about
stranger things happen no because he
lives here in Coral Gables
yeah Coral Gables Florida I mean again
when you look at element 115 that wasn't
around all sentence there they went to
to Bob's house about a month ago the FBI
did mmm why would they go there and do
that I mean if this guy really wasn't
what he said he was who cares
so obviously something was going on he
obviously struck a nerve with somebody
mom and what he was talking about was
down to 150 why don't you think I mean
uh when you watch his interview all of
his interviews and all of his podcasts I
mean it's it's almost it's really
[ __ ] hard not to believe what he's
talking about why would this guy be law
I mean he would have to have spent a lot
of time fabricating these stories and on
all the details in them well I think to
when people started to go back and kind
of do an investigation cuz listen nobody
wants to take anybody at face value you
know you look this is a pretty big story
you're like you're part of this really
really worked at s2 s4 there well yeah
but s2 is where this the
extra-terrestrial vehicles were actually
at s2 oh okay
so he initially when he came out wanted
just to share the information with
everyone and obviously you know the
powers to me did want to do that so they
discredited him and they a when the I'm
trying to think
I believe the reporter's name was nap
Daryl nap was the investigating reporter
so what he did was went back to the
University and asked for his university
record oh yeah because they were they
wiped his university right they were
dead and that was and so it what it did
was it made people kind of like me oh
I'll see you there Lazar you weren't
telling the truth to begin with now they
can't find a thing on you and it's kind
of oh really the government did all this
and like I say when you go back now all
this time has gone on all
he was discredited for so many things
like I said go look at the periodic
chart on the 115 is now on there he
talked about that element and whatever
else he had done and had recorded they
obviously thought that he had more
information there because they went to
his house right and Bob's not a Bob's
not a troublemaker he's not a you know
this guy has a PhD he's a highly
educated man who thought that the truth
should come out about hey listen the
American public a inhalant well I think
they can and I'm gonna come out let
everybody know that wants to know what's
going on hmm and I think when you take
that into consideration what he's done
for UFOs across the board helped us
better understand what we're seeing hmm
why they don't want to share this with
us whether we can handle it or not um
you know listen I'm real far from that's
that category but when you talk to
younger people today especially the
Millennials why are you far from that
category personally why do you think
you're far from that category um I tend
to I try to try to be the moderate I try
to be the guy in the middle yeah I want
to understand you know again why is it
that some people think that religion is
real or why is it you think UFOs are
real or why do you think Kennedy was
shot by this group or why did you think
that well it's fun to dive into all
these conspiracy theory wormholes on the
internet it's really fun and it's really
entertaining to do it but if if you're
somebody who's really looking for the
truth or is not gonna just tie yourself
to some idea and try to prove tell
everyone that you're right and they're
wrong
if you really believe something you
should be I mean this something we
talked about with Nathan crock basically
if you think something's real you should
be always trying to go out there and
prove it wrong find things that that go
against it absolutely you really want to
believe something to be true don't just
look for things that are gonna confirm
your beliefs search for the things that
are going to prove you wrong
sure and listen even what you know we
talk about these things and what event
in your life that happens or takes place
and I'll give you another story live
near the beach here yeah again dealing
with night vision we just got some new
night vision end and so I had never used
to before and I was gonna ready to go
over to SOCOM so I wanted to know where
do you get this stuff from
it just comes in from the manufacturers
okay there's there's a manufacturer just
does nothing
but night vision okay I are so we go
right to those guys and the lives units
are about three grand you know when you
start buying a map
most people won't go out and buy them
but as we put these Special Operations
teams together and I get the equipment
and bring it in and just to kind of get
to use it so I'm in the backyard and I'm
laying on my deck and I'm playing with
it and there's a thing called that they
talked about when I even with the
inventor called flaring and so I'm
laying on the back and I'm doing this
well out of the east come these two
balls alight and I'm looking I pulled
the night vision with my eyes I'm
looking through my vision I go I went if
that's a flare if that's called a flare
mmm what's going on so I put it back up
in my face real quick again and these
two balls of light that we had come out
of the East are still there I have two
real tall palm trees on the side of my
house they're probably 60 feet high and
these lights went around those trees I
mean I instantly jumped up into I was
looking at something without the night
vision on you couldn't see them yeah so
you know what does it take to prove
something like that to yourself I don't
I didn't run out and grab the newspaper
I go oh my god I saw these balls alight
you're not gonna believe this
these events were not a personal matter
but I think of you you know we share
what some people are looking at you're
like oh I think one of the Cougars got
out of Loony better yeah absolutely you
know so yeah so you know sometimes you
don't you base an opinion or a fact
based on hey this is what I've learned
through my years of seeing these things
or something like and well I think I
think that the best part about it about
what you're doing whatever whatever if
you want to call yourself a conspiracy
guy or you know a guy who's into all
these cuckoo conspiracy theories I mean
look at it from the point that at least
you're interested in you know you're
interested in it you're fascinated by it
sure and you're looking into it and
you're you're curious to what it is
people just want to push it away be like
I don't even want to think about that oh
yeah because that's labels me as a
cuckoo bird
and listen I'll touch it kind of it kind
of for me it's like reading a good novel
yeah you know how did you get there what
made you think this what gave you that
idea gee behind that and let's not even
take it with religion
I find religion very interesting when
you start looking through belief factors
of certain people or certain groups and
how strong their religion is or their
background or what their beliefs are and
listen it's it's a belief it's not based
on any fact you know it's just a belief
process okay you know when you start
looking at
and the people who don't believe in it
are I mean listen I believe President
Trump said that he has no doesn't care
about it one way or the other just
doesn't care
mm-hmm I find that hard to believe about
religion about UFOs about UFO UFOs he
just didn't care about UFOs it just
wasn't important you know listen there's
some that say John F Kennedy was killed
because he was trying to expose UFOs and
aliens and that they weren't just gonna
let that out that that kiddie out of the
bag yeah so you know again that when you
if I look for enough information I can
actually find stories that support that
theory and there's a group of people out
there I'm sure that would be absolutely
willing to die over oh I know this is my
County girls yeah of course so but what
makes them think that way